يظهر حجم الاضرار والخسائر التي خلفها
الزلزال يظهر كل ذلك مدى قوته فما الذي
يفسر سبب قوه زلزال عن غيره من
الناحيه الزلزال بلغت قوته سبعه فاصل
ثمانيه درجات وقد يعتقد البعض ان الفارقه
بين ست درجات وسبع درجات مثلا ليس كبيرا
لكن الحقيقه ان الدرجه الكامله على مقياس
رختر تعني عشره اضعاف القوه ايضا كان
الزلزال قريبا من سطح الارض حيث نشا على
عمق 18 كيلومتر فقط من السطح هذا يعني ان
الموجات الزلزاليه انتقلت بسرعه الى السطح
ما ادى الى اهتزازات حاده كما ان مركز
الزلزال وقع بالقرب من مدن وقرى ماهوله
بالسكان ما يفسر الاعداد الكبيره من
الوفيات والجرحى ومن بين العوامل الاخرى
المؤثره كثره الهزات الارتداديه التي
تجاوز عددها المئات ورغم ان الهزات
الارتداديه ليست بنفس قوه الهزات الرئيسيه
او الزلزال الرئيسي الا انها تعرقل عمليات
الانقاذ كما تتسبب في المزيد من الحطام
خاصه للمباني الايه للسقوط التي تضررت من
الزلزال الاصلي